as promised earlier in the show vision
board maker expert ron funches has
returned to help us make a vision board
for America because let's be honest we
could use a little vision or better
vision at that it's 20/20 and I'm saying
a better vision is funny so ron has it
been harder for you to find humor these
days a little bit it depends on the day
you know and I think that's what we have
to give ourselves as human beings it's
ok to fill down it's ok to feel sad it's
okay to feel angry but then it's also ok
to feel happy and enjoy your friends and
the people around you and keep your
happiness I think that's something I've
been really focusing on well Ron it
looks like you have a nice setup there
so is that a felt board yeah oh I've
been I've been upgraded ok so let's
build the board together what do you
have to put on it what's on ok well you
know we start with something some things
they're new and something say the same
the rock boom right in the middle there
because I think he's needed now more
than ever vote for him at this point
absolutely and also I want to work with
him on a new TV show he's making if he
listens if he watches this show this
looks good together yes it's gonna
happen so what's next but like you said
we got a voting ballot right there
because we got a vote we got a vote
things are going ways data that you no
matter what you feel changes needed we
needed some sensibility we've got to get
out there and vote you got to let your
voice be heard
I'm asked here because you gotta wear
that mask yes wearing masks and they got
to they got to my mom lives in Phoenix
Arizona and she says she goes out
shopping and nobody's wearing that mask
and I get worried about her so please
wear your mask it's just kind yep it's
just kind mil what's and it's smart so
what's the nuts next okay we got a
Statue of Liberty because we gotta have
Liberty and think right now this is
something that we need to remember as
our ideals our principle what this
country was founded on you know and just
remember where we came from so we can
get to where we need to go I think
that's important absolutely okay what's
next I got my own private island because
I need one we can all go there if
everything goes to crap
you're welcome Kelly you are most
definitely welcome all right what's next
we got a black lives matter sign because
I just think that's important for
everyone to remember it's not about
separation it's about togetherness and
that when one group is under attack
all our liberties are under attack and
we have to protect each other and
remember that black lives matter
especially for me as being a father of a
black son and a black son who has autism
it scares me often about what could
happen to him so I just want everyone to
remember that yes amen yes what's next
we got KitKat bar is that for the munch
answer cuz we need a break we need a
break and also the munchies and also you
know something when you out there doing
all this boat in and protesting and
stuff you get a little hungry you need
to you need to take a break okay wait
what what else and then last but not
least I have a nice little barbecue
grill here because I figure out that we
vote after we get everything together as
we come back together let's get together
eat grew up grill up some barbecue if
you're vegan we can put some portobellos
on a whole different grill for you luck
for America absolutely I know everything
can be solved with food I'm I think you
oh man after my own heart I love that
anyway thank you so much Ron it's always
good to see man you're so like just a
breath of fresh air you're so you just
make people happy that's a very amazing
gift you have with that oh thank you
very much that's a beautiful compliment
thank you yes subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going